hey guys it's max from Max tech today we
are comparing the brand new Dell XPS 75
90 laptop compared to its biggest
competitor the MacBook Pro that's the
latest generation one with an 8 core eye
9 processor Vega 20 graphics and we're
gonna see how these two stack up both in
terms of the hardware the quality and
performance
now as this powerhouse starts to boot up
let me set these side-by-side and tell
you guys about the price differences
because it is huge in these models my
macbook pro right over here has the base
2.3 gigahertz upto 4 point 8 gigahertz a
core CPU compared to the higher-end 2.4
to 5.0 in the Dell XPS I also have half
the SSD 512 instead of 1 terabyte the
same matter Ram and both have their
higher-end graphics cards Vega 20
compared to the 1650 4 gigabyte in the
Dell XPS and the price difference comes
in at $900 and then of course if you
want upgrade to the higher-end processor
in the MacBook Pro which is not worth it
or to one terabyte of SSD storage it's
an even bigger difference so the XPS
looks like there is a great value and a
lot of money that you could be saved if
you don't need Mac OS now one thing that
you can't argue about is the build
quality and the form factor the XPS is
built really well one of the best
Windows laptops but it still can't
compare to a unibody MacBook Pro design
which is quite a bit thinner and made of
completely aluminum both the hinge and
everything you really see the daleks PS
is quite a bit thicker I'm not sure if
it's heavier but definitely feels a
little bit heavier and it has aluminum
on the top and then the bottom panel now
along with that we have a big difference
with the actual keyboards the Dell XPS
uses a traditional kind of chiclet
design with more travel and I think that
overall most people are gonna prefer the
Dell XPS as keyboard if you're used to
standard ones I like the MacBook Pro
keyboards especially the latest ones
they're kind of less clicky and a little
bit softer with less noise than before
and of course they're the newest
generation and there is a big kind of
downside with MacBook Pros everybody's
nervous about them because of the
keyboard issues they've had in the past
Apple has promised to fix any issues if
the
rise and personally haven't seen them
but that's one downside with the MacBook
Pro positive though is the trackpad
MacBook Pro has this huge trackpad with
really good software so you actually
don't get very many missed types or miss
clicks if your palms are resting on
there and I love having this for
gestures whereas the Dell XPS even
though it's a pretty good track pad it
does not compare it is much smaller you
don't get that even click feel all
around and in general it just is on a
different level compared to the MacBook
Pros now as far as ports those do vary
quite a bit the XPS gives a traditional
layout that a lot of people enjoy we
have a standard USB a fast one here an
SD card reader which is freely really
nice to have a battery meter over here
and if we flip this guy around
I don't want unplug it cuz it's dead we
also have another USB port HDMI one
Thunderbolt 3 and then a headphone jack
so this is great for pro users that
don't want to deal with dongles or
adapters or anything like that now of
course on the MacBook Pro we have a
completely different layout and style we
still have a headphone jack thankfully
but we have four full-speed Thunderbolt
3 ports that is actually very powerful
if you want to hook things up like a 5k
display an external graphics card unit
hook it up to a cue nap nass or other
accessories you can have a ton of ports
and these could be adapted to pretty
much anything you can use cables with
the different connectors to avoid using
the little dongles and you can also hook
up a little amount that goes on here
gives you a lot of extra ports but it's
something that is harder to deal with
and gives an additional cost the Dell
XPS doesn't have that touch bar from the
MacBook Pro which honestly we're not
really fans of but it still does have
fingerprint login which is called
Windows hello we're gonna go ahead and
set this up right here I'm not sure how
reliable it is it doesn't have that
specific Enclave built into the chip so
as far as security I'm kind of iffy on
that but it still is very convenient to
log in and it should also have the face
recognition login as well which I am
Athena now what a huge difference
possibly the biggest difference is the
operating systems of course with the
MacBook Pro we have Mac OS and some
people are gonna buy the Mac just for
that
reason alone with the XPS we have
Windows 10 and just the initial setup we
have so much spam and so much built-in
stuff tough to get through airs right
when we log in the very first time and
along with that we have power management
so I'm gonna go ahead and disable all of
the power saving options and you really
want to be careful when you're doing
this because usually there's multiples
you have your windows power saving
options you also have your graphics card
and maybe even the built-in CPU so go
through and disable that if you want to
get the best performance one area that
the MacBook Pros have been known to
excel in is display quality for the last
couple of years we've had DCI p3 color
which is really good but now the dell
has it as well and it's also a 4k OLED
non-touch model for this one Wow very
interesting so olla typically is a
little bit more punchy out of the box
with better contrast and I could
definitely tell on the home screen it
was hard to tell but when we're watching
video like this it is noticeably sharper
even from a distance of about you know
two and a half three feet here looking
at this it looks nice I don't know about
for video editing if you have to tweak
the colors and calibrate it it does have
that dcpip three wide color gamut but
with code is this punchy they see maybe
a little bit too punchy for video work
now one thing that is very weird is that
the Dell XPS actually has a 400 nits
rating compared to 500 nits but looking
at these just straight on over here the
XPS actually looks brighter in the
brightest parts and maybe that's just
because of OLED I thought I would never
say that the MacBook Pros display looks
bland or not very good but in this
instance it definitely isn't stacking up
to the OLED that spaces display
definitely looks a lot better but one
area where the MacBook Pro excels is the
coating on the glossy display to kind of
reduce some of the glare some of the
reflections the XPS also has that but it
just doesn't do as you give it a job and
of course both these are glossy displays
so if you're using them outside the
MacBook Pro will do a better job in that
way along with that the MacBook Pro uses
a 16 by 10 display that means it is
taller over here and as
you can see we get a lot more vertical
space not only is that nice when your
web browsing but also if you're doing
video editing photo editing or really
pretty much anything else on a small
display like this so I went ahead and
turned on one of our favorite tracks to
test out speakers and this is another
strong seat of the MacBook Pro over the
years and has been a weakness of the del
so let's just go ahead and check out if
they have managed to improve it and
let's do our speaker test let's start
out with the del
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as you can tell that is a massive
difference right there alright guys so
we are now finally getting into
performance we're gonna start out with
Geekbench for keep in mind that the del
does have a slightly higher end I&I
processor whereas in the MacBook Pro we
have the lower one but because of how
thin the macbook pro is if you do spend
$200 extra you get basically no
performance difference unfortunately the
results are in and this is quite odd we
have a good single core score of 50 370
but the multi-core is actually lower at
28,000 751 and I did some research and
other people are getting similar results
so even though the CPU is better inside
the XPS the overall performance is
actually a little bit lower on the
positive side I just reran Geekbench 4
except with the XPS unplug like the
MacBook Pro was and the scores are
relatively similar we're not seeing a
huge drop in performance that is great
the multi-core went down just a bit but
the single core actually went up now
let's jump in and take a look at
Cinebench r20 which is gonna max out the
CPUs like it would if you're doing
rendering we're about 75% done now and
the XPS is noticeably loud the fans are
spinning up quite a bit the MacBook is
still silent
but of course Apple likes to run their
things hot whereas the Dell even when I
was going through some web browsers the
fans would actually kick up I can't get
a bit annoying but you can't kind of
tweak that in the settings if you would
like and there we have it 31 83 on the
MacBook Pro compared to 33 81 for the
Dell XPS so once we put a full
hundred-percent CPU load on the XPS it
does come out ahead compared to
Geekbench 4 and also I want to say that
that was with the XPS unplugged we're
not seeing a performance difference at
least not in the CPU which is fantastic
because in the past we actually did now
assess out the graphics here I have
Unigine Heaven a gaming benchmark open
wow this is very interesting the 1650
scored 40 3.7 FPS compared to 41.1 on
the Vega 20 MacBook Pro that is very
very close and I was not expecting that
the mega 20 MacBook Pro actually scored
lower in our previous test so I think
maybe it's just Mack West that has been
updated with better drivers and giving
us a better result now before we take a
look at video editing results let's do a
quick disk speed test both these have
nvme SSDs let's see how they stack up
we're getting about 1,800 to 2,000 right
on the lap MacBook in about 1600 right
on the Dell XPS and as far as read we're
getting about 2900 on MacBook Pro and
about 2300 on the XPS now the results
can vary based on what program you're
using of course I typically use
Blackmagic speed test which shows
slightly higher for the MacBook Pro but
the settings are identical for this test
right here just to give us an even kind
of comparison so our MacBook Pro is on
top as far as the speeds but the dell
doesn't disappoint this is pretty good
performance and of course we have double
the storage for a much lower price now
finally let's jump into video editing
I'm at a boot up Premiere Pro and let's
take a look at how they perform let's
start out with the standard timeline
test as far as the smoothness I have dog
ears enabled which is showing me this
display see if we dropped any frames and
what the FPS is like full resolution 4k
this is with two lutz and film grain
here and both systems are playing this
back perfectly smoothly so that is
really good either one of these can
handle reading their 4k editing with
some effects and color Corrections stuff
like that they're both high-end pcs so
that doesn't make sense
but let's jump into something a little
bit more difficult this is 4k 60 row
footage let's go ahead and playback here
at full resolution and see how they do
so it looks like the XPS is running so
far about 18 frames per second and
dropping our MacBook Pro is running at
about 12 and dropping let's let it
stabilize here and it looks like the
performance difference isn't where I
hoped it would be our MacBook Pros
actually running about 8 frames per
second which is terrible the XPS was
running at about 7 fps here at the end
let's go ahead and export that 4k
project that's what most people edit
with the h.264 and see what our expert
times look like wow the results are in
and as you can see the XPS took almost 6
minutes
here it's a four and a half on the
MacBook Pro and this is only a five
minute project that is surprising and
that's with XPS plugged-in let's run it
one more time with XPS on battery power
so you were editing on the go and the
results are basically the same just
about a two-second difference so that is
good that the next PS doesn't slow down
if you unplug it at least in this
scenario where we're not pushing
everything to the max the previous
generation slowed down quite a bit if
you are in battery power and you want it
to export video but overall I'm quite
surprised that the XPS even though it
has a faster processor better cooling
and the actual benchmarks turned out
better the graphics card is more
powerful in all reality for this kind of
work the MacBook Pro is still ahead I am
really shocked but either way this thing
does provide a better value because
we're saving about nine hundred dollars
and you're getting double the SSD
storage on top of that you can actually
upgrade and change the RAM yourself if
you would like of course we have a
variety of different ports here not just
Thunderbolt three but unfortunately we
only have one Thunderbolt 3 port which I
really wish they gave us at least two
because if you fill one up I mean you
know you want to hook up a high end
display or a raid array or something
else then you're kind of out of luck so
let me know your thoughts would you by
the new dell XPS or would you pick up
one of these new MacBook Pros I want to
hear your guys's opinions down in the
comment section below this has been max
with Mac's tech and I'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]